um all right uh trey lance the
third overall pick in the draft
painstakingly selected by the 49ers oh
it was the guy they were going to draft
all along never mind trey lance says
he's looking forward to learning as much
as he can from jimmy garoppolo
make your own joke uh on that but
look trey lance didn't ask to be thrust
into this awkward spot that's right
he is he is and it's it's inherently
awkward
you got the guy that's the starter that
took the team to the super bowl that the
locker room is behind
and the team has written him off now the
organization not the locker room the
organization's written him off because
he can't stay healthy but he's still
there and is he going to start is he
going to play who knows
meanwhile trey lance is trying to figure
out this whole nfl thing
while there's this potentially toxic and
poisonous
situation to to navigate that
trevor lawrence doesn't have that zack
wilson doesn't have
that to a certain extent justin fields
doesn't have because
right you know we know it's a matter of
time before he leap frogs andy dalton
and andy dalton's got no history with
the bears there's no one in that locker
room
that is the slightest bit chaffed about
the prospect of justin fields putting
andy dalton on the bench so
this is just a you know now we are 17
days removed from the draft
and this is where you know you absorb
the guy onto the team and you make it
work
but but there's a natural inherent
awkwardness to the situation that trey
lance is going to have to figure out how
to deal with chris
a hundred percent mike i mean yeah that
that that's that's the current status of
the situation with the 49ers
hey it's it's you you kind of said it
you unpacked it there it's rare
i mean think about what we're talking
about here you know yes
it's a quarterback for an organization
who's
he wins he wins a lot for their team
jimmy garoppolo when he's on the field
but that's the big if
so there's that aspect and yes the last
time he was on the field
all the time they were you know going to
the super bowl
so it is rare to see a team try to
replace somebody like that
that makes the situation more intense
and the microscope on it and everything
like that let alone
like the draft circumstances that you
mention
and everything like that that makes me
know more pressure on the situation
and makes it more awkward and everything
about it so
uh yeah it's it's an amazing situation
it really is
we're looking at a team that i think you
and i
and most people in football go they're
in the super bowl window
but yet how often do we say that about a
team and go
but but they need a quarterback but they
want to change their quarterback that's
the weirdest thing on their football
team
and i think that's what makes you know
everything like you're talking about
just a different set of circumstances
here
you almost need to have one member of
the coaching staff assigned to trey
lands to constantly whisper in his ear
it's okay it's all right you're the guy
you're the guy
don't worry about it it's fine it's fine
it'll be fine you're the guy that's
going to be here for the next 15 years
this will pass uh kyle shanahan
appearing with michael irvin on his
podcast talking about
the possibility that trey lance will
indeed start despite the
fact that everyone in the organization
is sending the message that jimmy
garoppolo is their guy
in 2021 let's hear from coach shanahan
you're saying that somehow if trey comes
in
and he's off the charts he looks like
incredible on the field he looks
incredible
in practice there's a chance that trey
can right now win the starting job
as the quarterback yeah there's a chance
there's a chance for that at every
single position on our team so there
definitely is the way that you're saying
about trey i'm not trying to give florio
some a big headline that he makes
an annoying statement out of it but oh
yeah there it is
i think that'll be very hard jimmy's a
really good quarterback
he's not just coming in and trying to
take out some bridge quarterback or
something
jimmy is the guy who we've brought here
to be our franchise quarterback and it
really worked out for one year
and it doesn't mean it can't work out we
just hope he stays healthy
[Music]
three years as a head coach has aged
kyle so badly hey kyle
if you're worried about me you're
definitely worrying about the wrong
things i can tell you that
for damn sure if you're worrying about
what i'm gonna say about what you say
you should worry more about what you
say not what i'm going to say about what
you say i'm not the one that said jimmy
garoppolo has to stay alive until sunday
well
i didn't say he never said jimmy
garoppolo has to stay alive either he
made a reference to the whole team you
made a headline that said jimmy
garoppolo how to stay alive
i mean he's the one who had to say that
he blew that statement we can quibble
over the details no i
i understand yeah i i mean listen hey
hey big guys
you're part of this so what just deal
with it no no no no
no no i don't care yeah i don't care hey
i listen i'm
listen i i could be like calling card
and say oh you know he's he's paying
he's listening he's reading my website
he's
he's listening to me i don't care about
that what i care about
is why in the hell does a guy who has
far better things to worry about than me
worried about me do you think bill
belichick would ever say anything like
that i don't think bill belichick even
knows who the hell i
am no he does and he complains and i
have all he wants but he does
i have compared kyle shanahan to bill
belichick right i am not going to change
my assessment of kyle shanahan as a
coach
i don't like how the organization has
handled the past two months and i'm not
afraid to say so
i don't like this weird shell game that
i think they're playing with themselves
over what the hell they're going to do
at quarterback and i think it all traces
to
blowing it on patrick mahomes blowing it
on tom brady
and this year they freaked out and the
the
the result of this multi-week freak out
is where we are right now well hey
listen i mean i don't deny
any of that you know but i'm not gonna
sit here and get mad like listen
mike you're you're you're kind of a big
part of the nfl
no i mean no no no no no no no no no no
no most coaches in football
no i'm this is dead serious i'm not
trying to give you
no most shut up you're gonna have to
hear it
you're gonna have to hear it be fine
you're most coaches are paying attention
to your website
your your website is a huge part of the
narrative that goes on in the nfl
it is so he doesn't he's he's just
being very self-aware and yeah maybe
taking a little fun
shot at you as he goes there all right
what's fun for me
well yeah it was it was all right you're
good no
you're good as tough as you are it is
stubborn sob that you are you're fine
don't you worry
i i and i like kyle and i'm not going to
change my opinion of it because of that
that's fine he can he can say what he
wants i'm a big boy i can take it but
part of our job is to call out bs and i
think a lot of bs has been flowing out
of the 49ers headquarters strategically
because you can't always bear your soul
i get it you can't come out and say
exactly what you want to do
i still think it was odd for them to
play whatever game they played once they
moved up to the third spot
they knew they were getting whoever was
left after trevor lawrence or zach
wilson
worst case scenario they get one of
those two guys instead
no one was going to jump them for
whoever they wanted they just
they've created this gratuitous
unnecessary mystery
yeah and it's and it's led to this this
this stew that they're now gonna have to
pick through
to make sure trevor lawrence is okay the
locker room's okay what are we gonna do
with jimmy g
it it's it's it's just more trouble than
it's worth for a team that is on the
cusp of being a super bowl team a super
bowl winner they've already been a super
bowl team
they're on the cusp of being a super
bowl winner yeah now mike listen i i'm
not going to argue much with what you
said there you're right some of the
optics of the way the things were done
with the draft and everything like that
yeah they're a little weird i don't know
what else to say you know shanahan lynch
did what they thought they had to do
to make sure they got the right
quarterback yeah i don't buy some of the
stuff they're selling either
i'm with you i don't know if they really
need to make that move up there that
aggressively and do all that
as well but obviously they felt a real
desperate need
that they needed to get rid of jimmy
garoppolo or that they need to make a
move to start that
process going and that they like these
quarterbacks
and i just think with that comment there
even though it's like
you know of course and all that you know
it's i i
think it's a very real possibility again
like we said
we know there's got to be competition
and it's not going to be easy to beat
jimmy garoppolo like
shanahan said and all those type of
things but to what you said
they've made a mess of the bed and it's
a big situation and there's a microscope
on it i think that makes more pressure
to put the guy
in and play let alone the fact that we
discussed many times like the biggest
issue is he hasn't played enough anyways
so you know i i think that as long as
that trey lands continues to show
growth and improvement that the
situation's not too big
you know i i do think that they're gonna
do their best to get him in there and
get him in there early and i wouldn't be
shocked to see him start in week one i
think shanahan has the offense and the
brains and the scheme
and the creativity to bring a guy like
that along
and not have it be like all on him and
he's going to blow the game
with one pass or something like that let
me ask you this yes
if there's any truth to the notion
that when they made the move from 12 to
3 back in late march kyle shanahan
intended to select alabama quarterback
mac jones
and was gradually persistently
and inevitably nudged toward trey lance
right
and it really wasn't the guy he wanted
does that make kyle
more likely to say he's not ready
or does it make it more likely for him
to accelerate it as a message to whoever
wanted him hey we want a guy who's game
ready you think he's game ready here we
go
let's see here let's put him out there
and see what he can do you guys are the
ones that pushed me for him
i wanted a guy who's ready to play we're
gonna find out if he's ready to play
which way do you think he's more likely
to go i think to accelerate it i think
the whole situation has more pressure on
it to like accelerate it and make it go
and like yeah you know some of the
optics around it to like what you're
saying yeah
i'm definitely a believer and the people
i know around the league and things like
that yeah i think that they
they made that move for mac jones i do
you know and i don't
again i think also with the optics of
the situation it's like you said it's a
team that's a super bowl ready
and almost everybody the one thing
everybody was in consensus about
was that mac jones was the most pro
ready day one guy
so that's to me where i still believe
that that move was made for him
um but yeah i think with all those
things we've talked about
i do i think it does put more pressure
on him
and on shanahan and like trey lance to
kind of
get this ball rolling and and get it
going and start playing football
uh i haven't thought about it a lot but
i think so mike i think it does don't
you
i i could see it some level you do
either way
my my theory is that there's some
svengali in that organization that
allows kyle to move on his own to the
place where they want him to go just
like when he
pivoted from kirk cousins to jimmy
garoppolo in 2017
and john lynch is the one out of whose
mouth the truth from time to time
accidentally
emerges like when he said kyle was in
mourning when he didn't get kirk cousins
and he got jimmy garoppolo instead but i
feel like there's somebody there
who convinces kyle on his own to pivot
in a different direction and if that's
what happened if kyle
genuinely made the decision on his own
and he doesn't realize there's somebody
that's trying to
you know pull the strings to get him to
do it then he is all in with trey lance
and he's all in with the plan on trey
lance
and and and you know he's not going to
say well
i'm you know this guy's not ready this
guy's not ready you guys wanted him look
he's not ready i got to go with jimmy g
i wanted mac jones no
kyle got to the point where he wanted
trey lance so he's gonna be all in with
trey lane i agree
and it does make sense to get him on the
field sooner than later
and i know that jed york has said oh
it's a good problem to have if jimmy
garoppolo comes in and they play really
well but but
i don't think that's a good problem
that's not a good problem to have
it's not it's a disaster actually it's
it's not like the guy walks out the door
and steps on a banana peel and breaks
his leg
he played the full 2019 season chances
are he'll play the full 2021
season and the team is very good despite
his flaws
yeah then you have a problem yeah i
agreed that that's to me the dicey part
of the situation like we talked about
early on in this this you know right
after the draft before the draft right
i mean we talked about it you could see
the scenario jimmy garoppolo starting
and oh it's week 10 and the 49ers are
eight and two
okay it doesn't look like trey lance is
playing this year oh wait the 49ers went
to the playoffs
you know and lost only a handful of
games and maybe won a playoff game maybe
two
okay now we're gonna make the change now
with all the pressure and
more people in the locker room and the
fan base liking jimmy garoppolo even
more now
that's yeah that's to me i'm with you
mike that that is
that's trouble that's how you can have a
real issue in an organization so
uh that that's where i would favor
getting lance on the field as well
you better be damn sure that trey lance
is patrick mahomes because it was never
an issue in kansas city when they nudged
alex smith aside
after consistently going to the playoffs
and realizing there was only so far he
could take them
if you don't bring in a guy who takes
you farther you got a problem
so it puts more eggs in that basket for
trey lance if that's
how it plays out but i still think that
number one
they're hoping for a pathway to trade
jimmy garoppolo and get maximum value
and number two if lance is ready to go
i'm telling you mid to late august
they approached don garoppolo's agent
say we can't pay you 25 million this
year we'll pay you 12.
and if you can't do that we're gonna
have to let you go period because our
other guy's ready
sorry jimmy we paid you a lot of money
over the past few years
we're sorry it's not it's come to this
but this is just the way it is i mean
that that's one way that the dominoes
fall
if trey lance is ready and if the 49ers
don't get an opportunity
to unload that contract yeah no i i
could see that i could see i mean
yeah you know there's there's some
wiggle room here for the 49ers
and i do agree with you in the fact that
you know they could stand pat for right
now
see where things go you're right trey
lance does well
in training camp preseason okay there's
a team that needs somebody maybe that's
when they do try to you know maximize
their trade value for jimmy garoppolo
something like that
but yeah if that doesn't happen and as
of right now there's not really going to
be any suitors out there for jimmy g
unless something happens then it's like
okay
so what's gonna happen now is trey lands
gonna start week one
we're gonna start jimmy g and infuse
trey lance into certain plays during the
game
or are we gonna start jimmy g with the
mind of like
what what the dolphins did last year
where they could go
screw it we're five and two but we don't
give a damn we're taking
fitzpatrick out and we're going with our
rookie
i don't know that's that's on the table
too so
maybe that's something that you know
they got some they got some different
avenues to
to take here and we'll see how it plays
out and if they let this thing play out
through training camp in the preseason
the one
risk that they consciously are taking is
the possibility that the serious
quarterback injury happens to them
garoppolo tears in acl and 25 million
dollars is gone forever because at that
point he goes on ir and he gets every
penny of it so
it's all calculated it's all deliberate
there's a plan but there is risk
every step of the way hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports